Colombia marcó su triste récord de
homicidios de líderes sociales en 2022
la cifra más alta desde que se empezó
este registro en 2016 según el defensor
del pueblo Carlos Camargo esta situación
es especialmente preocupante ya que se
trata de líderes que recogen las
inquietudes de la gente no solo se trata
de cifras hay que pensar en 215 familias
duramente golpeadas y en las comunidades
afectadas que se quedan sin las personas
que luchan por sus derechos esto es una
grave afectación para la base de la
Democracia cinco departamentos fueron
especialmente afectados ya que coinciden
con las zonas con mayor presencia de
grupos armados ilegales nariño cauca
Antioquia putumayo y el Valle del cauca
reunieron la mitad de estos crímenes 63
de las víctimas eran líderes comunales
que generalmente promueven la
sustitución de cultivos ilícitos 47
líderes indígenas también fueron
asesinados seguidos por comunitarios
campesinos afrodescendientes sindicales
y activistas de Derechos Humanos esta
violencia está vinculada principalmente
con la persistencia de economías
ilegales fuertes en Colombia como el
narcotráfico como la minería criminal la
gran escala y también está vinculado al
fortalecimiento de grupos armados
organizados debido a la falta o la
ausencia de una política de seguridad
Clara en el gobierno anterior de Iván
Duque y también la falta de voluntad
política para implementar el acuerdo de
paz que tuvimos en el anterior gobierno
este lunes el eln valoró de manera
positiva los resultados de la reunión
extraordinaria que celebró con
representantes del gobierno colombiano
en Caracas tras haber desmentido el
anuncio de cese el fuego hecho por el
propio presidente Gustavo Petro la
defensoría colombiana Espera que dichos
procesos lleven a una disminución de las
acciones contra los líderes en Colombia
sin embargo en lo que va de este año ya
se han contabilizado seis asesinatos de
líderes sociales